so tell me you do how'd you get involved
Oh
so how did I get started well I'll let
you know a little bit of my story and
that's all right so I kind of started I
was at university in Bermuda uni I was
doing business management and public
policy there it was all cool and
everything you know I was learning a lot
but then I actually kind of got into
personal development and then I kind of
realized you know I'm not sure if you
need really the main way for me to be
learning or you know which should I
really be learning from these lecturers
who aren't millionaires for example and
I should be learning from people who are
millionaires or where I want to be and
these guys weren't really getting the
position I wanted to be in so I still
carried on uni I finished uni for my
parents they wanted me to finish that
and then I got into a sales role and
during that sales role that's when I
started to pay rent for for my parents
and that and I thought to myself okay
that's 500 pounds a month rent how am I
gonna like how am I gonna pay for that I
don't want to pay that on my own pockets
and then come up with a kind of business
to do and then I went onto YouTube as
everyone does and then came across you
the first video I saw of yours was
actually on lease options and this is
actually when you had less than 10,000
subscribers so a while ago a while ago
and you're like one of the loyal well
and it was actually when you had your
you know your first intro it used to
have that wit that funny music and it
was purple oh yeah that's when you
that's when I first started seeing it
anyway I think you in you had some like
wooden background and you did your your
videos and stuff yeah so as a while ago
and then so then I started to look into
rent to rent I start you study what it
used to be so business management public
policy okay I mean like there get me
wrong it's okay to know that kind of
stuff now like balance sheets and stuff
but in terms of like entrepreneurial
stuff they make money yeah making money
that's not they teach you like you know
you know they teach you to be an
employee or worker kind of thing they
never teach you how to is really you
know I did business manager
I never really said oh this is how to
open a company this is company's house
yeah these are insurances they never how
to get paid yeah this is how you get
paid your business they never really
told you it's funny because they never
you taught you how to run a business or
start a business it's not a business
management so I get I get attacked a lot
because I talk about University and I
want to say a bad light see I think
universities great yeah foot for some
people but to go to university without a
plan or if you want to be an
entrepreneur you want to be a property
investor mean to go to university and
study proper to your business it's just
it's just a real slow way oh definitely
I agree with that because I mean like I
was there for like four years and then I
thought to myself I've learned more in
the last three months from these books
and audio books and going to courses and
seminars than I have in the entire time
I was at uni yeah thinking you're on I
loved uni I got where my independence
and I learned how to cook and I learned
a few different I learned a few schools
I learned a few skills like body
language and a few other things well I'm
kind of you kind of hoped you though for
years
Mendon how much nine hundred year Oh
something silly I mean like there's like
I think average people are liking forty
fifty thousand in debt
do you think most people go to
university just to please their parents
yeah but then also not just to please
their parents but also in my case anyway
because you're so young at eighteen who
really knows what they want to do with
Nadine mmm
no one really knows I didn't know all I
knew that at that time was that I wanted
to go to uni my friends were going to
you but would you not be better off 18
years old having a batch of business
going out in the real world and trying
to make some money and then after four
or five years you just didn't want to go
to you now yeah and go do you know I
mean it depends on personal preference
really I mean like for me I like to have
this conversation with somebody
yesterday I was like I wouldn't I still
even on this much in debt and the way my
life has gone in this way it could have
been better if I worked first and maybe
I could have had pocket five bought five
houses already seventh being in that
debt and Auntie you're not working in
unique so you're kind of messing around
really yeah half the time yeah but I
would say that it's really personal
preference I wouldn't take anything I
would never I wouldn't go back on it
like I would still probably do it again
just because of the experience and how I
kind of turned out I think
that's my personal opinion but in terms
of like if you're just looking to if
you're going to unique just to get a
good job a good paying job and I'll say
you know maybe think about something
else to do a bit of some development
self talking about personal relevant I
mean most people that go to you know go
to school to get good grades to go to
university to ultimately to get a job
and the purpose of a job for most people
is to pay the money yeah so why not skip
all that nonsense and just learn yet had
to get had to get money yeah and I think
I noticed what you did do it on a
personal development journey yeah you
did do some training with with myself
talking about what do you mean my
personal development and was it born I
think just in terms of mindset because
before before I kind of went into the
personal development like route of
different books prior to the personal
development I know I hated picking up a
book honestly I hated it just because it
was like mainly text you know when you
when you're in school it's all text it's
like eerie stuff like this I couldn't
really honestly say it's just like I was
just boring anyway yeah there's a stuff
that you know you're not really
interested in but in person development
is it was interesting because as soon as
you read a couple pages you're like okay
I've actually added value to myself I
can now talk about something new a new
subject that's actually interesting that
can add value to someone's life yeah or
something like that and so what roller
coaster aluminum books did you read the
first one I personally I honestly think
that the best one for me and I think
everyone should start with this book a
lot of people say oh you know like I
think & Grow Rich you know what I saw
for me I personally think I look for the
compound effect yeah by Darren Hardy
yeah as soon as I read that was really a
simple book so small so simple so
compact but honestly just implement what
he says and then it's crazy honestly and
that's all about well it got compounding
yeah but not just money you can also
compound your time yeah exactly so it's
like oh doing one thing eating eating
one chocolate bar every single day
that's only a hundred calorie chocolate
bar a little thread though let's say you
know but over 20 years over 20 years
you're going to be putting on a couple
stone but yeah or you just change it to
a salad once a day then your
lose a couple stone and it's like
compounding overtime or he was like
after you get a coffee every day most
people some people get coffees every day
and there's like oh I might pay pay pay
three to four-pound a day at Starbucks
yeah and then over a 20-year period you
could have bought yourself a Mercedes or
something or you know and then just
they're just like little tips like you
know simple things and I guess they make
their own coffee over the time and with
you instead of like most people maybe
watching music videos and scrolling on
Facebook and you're watching my videos
on you Matthew exactly binge watched all
the videos came on to the crash course
last year yeah exactly
mm yeah I'm juju to come again meet you
to come again and what what happened to
the crash course and what why did you
come and what happened well I don't need
this to come just to see what's really
happening you know I mean that you it's
different when you're on YouTube you're
on YouTube and everything and to be fair
to be fair to you though you're awesome
even on YouTube you still motivating and
everything but then when you get to the
crash course you bring some fireman you
bring quiet FL it's cool I mean I think
I personally I'm when my mom was there
she she she said this as well you know
you're already powerful kind of person I
think maybe she's she mention she was
like because about your church
background maybe yeah that you kind of
had that you know you've got that real
energy about you that real vibe about
you and I think that's really cool I
think not just me but I think when you
are learning the powerful techniques but
then also an environment where you can
actually do them yeah it's almost the
difference between oh I see it when you
read a theory book on how to drive and
then you actually go in the car yeah
when they're driving instructor and you
drive yourself that's kind of what we
try and make happen at the crash course
yeah that was awesome actually because
even even in the crash course I was when
I went to the crash course at the time
it would've been awesome I wanted to
actually go on one of your further
courses but I couldn't because I was
nervous learning about there's a
property stuff I don't paid for a course
just prior I didn't have any funds at
the time to go for further training and
I was that class sucked but at the time
the information that you gave on the
crash course was amazing honestly
amazing I mean like because I've been to
some other ones when people were like
all you know they a cop they pay a
couple hundred pounds or whatever to
give literally the same if not worse
information
you were giving for free which is which
is which is also saying when you give
this so what happened at the crash
course and and and I know now you've
done pretty well yeah you're financially
free yeah
congratulations you may go how much you
make in a month so we're making actually
from next year we'll be hitting the
six-figure mark nice yeah which is
awesome but what about rose that's gross
what about right now per month per month
it's about 5 5 k yeah and you have 26
your age 20 aren't well I'm 29 oh I mean
I wish I wish I was like I wish so a
little bit younger I really okay that's
cool that but do people think I'm older
so Isaac um okay cool so so how he built
that up what what what when did you
first deal what did your first deal what
were the figures oh you know what so the
first one was actually kind of risky it
was a risky one I was it was obviously
was risky it was a one-bedroom flat yeah
that's why it was a one-bedroom flat and
you rented this and I rented this one
yet
so you went to rent was really opposed
to this year concept yeah yeah about
went to me yeah yeah she was and that's
one of the reasons why you brought up
yeah this is my boy but then at the same
time I mean like even though she still
didn't really agree with it at the time
but but because I was owning my own
money and stuff I didn't ask her for a
single penny or anything like yeah she
had no she can say for me not to do
anything because obviously I make my own
money I can do what I kind of want with
it
me yes I started that I've got my first
rent rent which was a one-bedroom and it
wasn't even like amazing was it wasn't
it wasn't in the central occasion
anything like that but my my first goal
was I just want to make nothing crazy
just 500 pounds extra month yeah that
was it that was my goal then I luckily I
took took it on in the summer in June
yeah June so started in July and that
first month I think I made about 1500
profit nice because I turned it was a
one-bedroom and I turn the lounge or
sofa bed and start about now about what
six months sorry we're going back about
six months no no this is a bit further
than that this is about this is this is
about other through the last year this
is last year so you saw a one bed at one
better pop yeah yeah and the rent was
how much the rents eight to five and
reading so it's not sure it's not that
yeah yeah but it was eight to five and
then council tax and bills and
everything it comes to about flat a 100
by 1000 pounds interesting reading
that's where you live yes and also a lot
of people say that around the London
area and Wrentham it doesn't work yeah
do you can't do do you have to go up
north yeah yeah no you can do I
personally think in my opinion from what
I've learned now anyway is that you can
whatever if you take one of your doing
service accommodation any way that you
can most likely take on a property and
worst case scenario I for me anyway is a
break is a break even on a month like I
never ever lost money never taken money
on my pocket anything like that and I've
been doing this now for over yeah but
yeah it just means that the figures that
you've got this isn't like oh yeah I
just did a deal last month yeah you've
been only for over a year now you can
see the the figures coming in exactly
making up on average about five grand a
month yeah it's just great yeah so that
property then you did that serviced
accommodation service accommodation yeah
okay and then we then it took on another
one another one bedroom again later on
and then we've taken on a four bedroom
house so that lets just think with that
warm bed pool no quick right so you're
paying eight to five and how much we
then renting out per night for oh that's
the thing I mean at that time I said it
was risky in terms of light I just took
a chance like it wasn't it wasn't
central location or anything but it was
just close enough and just far enough
out so it's just far enough out there's
a nice country kind of area but yeah and
you're a 5 to 10 minute drive you have a
break walls a break laws yeah yeah we
had the break was another it was it was
six months but landlord is so happy with
it but you know what that's interesting
because a lot of people would say it's
real high risk oh my gosh young even
come to the crash course this point you
actually just watch videos ain't you
yeah so so if he doesn't go if he
doesn't go well you're screwed but
actually you've got six month break laws
you know that you're gonna at least
cover your costs exact worst case you're
gonna walk away exactly it's not the end
of the world I definitely not and
obviously just because I knew someone
else in the air one of my friends are
done air B&B as well so I asked him
about how did it kind of go for them
kind of thing I mean you know just try
out so I just tried it and well it's
everything just have gone gone from
there and it's awesome to be honest with
you so that one deal then
how much you making off that first deal
what you did what now yeah I think
currently do you know what for that
one-bedroom flat it varies it can vary
from 500 to like 1300 profit a month no
yeah that's right though yeah which is
awesome for a one-bedroom I mean I knew
only wanted 500 I only wanted 500
exactly so in the first month cave I've
pretty much broke even on my first month
almost pulled all my money out that I
invested in because there's part
furnished January which is awesome
and then spend that much I put in I put
in for rent furniture and everything
about two and a half thousand pounds so
you put two and a half grand in you make
him back between five hundred and
thirteen hundred a month off that one
deal I mean it's a brilliant deal it's
insane I mean like when I said when
people start saying well why would you
do that I'm thinking why wouldn't you
want to do that yeah why wouldn't you
Anna like kind you know making thirty
percent on your money almost every month
in a way or getting once you get and
once you make you money about doing
infinite returns right crazy crazy money
yeah so you did that deal and then you
thought wow yeah I'm just gonna rinse
and repeat this yeah literally but it
took me a while though because I still
had a beginner at this time you know I
mean you know still because that that
deal was was done through networking it
wasn't done for like estate agents and
stuff like that but now we've kind of
moved forward to start taking on better
properties how did you find a agents and
stuff how did you find out oh I think
I'd you know what I think it was
actually it was a from a fam it was
actually from a friend who I was letting
them know kind of what I wanted to do
and they introduced me to this landlord
basically yeah who they knew wanted to
hear trouble selling renting or
something because he wanted to high rent
or something like that
perfect yeah exactly it's perfect you
want you want that rents not a little
bit over inflate my friend I'll give it
you on the basis that it works like this
exactly it's like when people were
trying to sell the house for Dubai and
you say look I'll give you the price you
want but I'll pay on my terms and then
you do a lease option agree so it's
brilliant when people want too much yeah
definitely definitely I didn't know that
back in the day because I would have
back in the day folders saw someone you
wanted too much I wouldn't just bail on
us in my mind I want to discount on a
discount is that but actually when you
know how to charge super rent and we you
know the structure deals profitably then
you can say you know what that's
overinflated but I'll give you what you
want on my terms
yeah exactly that's cool it's cool I
love it I do love it so what so after
that deal man you got another what you
got another apartment yes there then the
the next one was another
same same same thing one-bedroom and
everything like that so that was cool
that one is going actually pretty well
all right ready yes all of them are
everything we have is in Reading
Berkshire area yeah
just because it's closer to us you know
yeah like we working like Bracknell
Windsor not Slough yet I'm thinking
about going into Slough actually do you
think regiment would work in Slough
I think so yeah yeah just because you
know like Slough then they got business
up there reading as a business hub and
just because like yeah just like in the
surrounding areas people like staying
that people might be working in reading
but live in Slough or working a Slough
but want to live in Redding kind of do
you only do serviced accommodation
ordinary reading instead we do that as
well yes we do rent - HM oh that's
that's we started getting into that more
recently yeah we started on serviced
accommodation but then after after
looking at service accommodation we're
kind of thinking okay cool service
accommodations is really good strategy
but let's get something a little bit
more consistent in terms of like okay so
we know we're gonna get 700 pounds
example a month from this property as
long as it's filled out
yes it's guaranteed in a way if it's
long as it's filled out so we're doing
both essays and HMOs now we're so so
let's say right now you're looking to
get a rent - hmm in reading or Slough
right what are the next steps how do you
find the landlord how do you speak to
them what do you say well it depends
really I mean like right now it's right
now things have been going well is that
because I've been now because now I'm
financially free it's actually awesome
that I go to this spa almost every day
like it sounds like sauna and that sauna
and steam just to you know just to relax
and stuff and get your thoughts together
I know you meet a lot of people in the
sauna you're honestly a lot of people in
the sauna and you like they're half the
people in these kind of places they own
their own businesses and they most a lot
of them own their own houses and stuff
like that so I wouldn't really be
networking to be honest with you and
also now we have a few relationships for
the state agents and stuff so we'll just
be calling them but if I was to say if I
was a complete beginner what would I be
doing probably
on open rent going on gumtree and
probably scouring a few Facebook groups
as well that kind of stuff if I was a
beginner again it's interesting because
it does get easier as it goes on and
also when you have deals you just
mentioned during the sauna but when you
are financially strong or infinity frame
even if you just full-time property yeah
you suddenly you lose that desperation
for the deal then I know when I started
out I was so desperate for a deal and
desperation all it does is it makes
people run away from you where words
when you're like I've done this before I
feel I'm not desperate anymore you then
come in from a position of abundance
where you can actually help landlords
you can offer them a good service it's
so true as well because it's like it's
kind of like people are like kind of
like cats in a way I learned this thing
when I was in New Year people are like
cats like if you chase someone or if you
chase a cat what does the Caddy that
runs away yeah it runs away so what do
you do but if you leave the cap you
leave it and you let the cat come to you
eventually then they will come to you
eventually
so like oh if it deals not happening now
don't chase them leave it they'll
eventually come back to you kind of
thing if you know it's kind of I think
that's so true you don't want to chase
anybody know exactly even even even even
the girls it's the same story that's
probably it slow faster than that are
you have you got a family you married no
no I'm not you've got a girlfriend oh I
was gonna give you a shout-out 20 the
female know anyway yeah not many though
we have like 90 percent male 1 yeah
that's true I don't know what it is what
do you think what do you think guys no
I'm a breadwinners you know they've got
a support family we've got a maze I mean
think I think it's just still there's a
lot of females oh and more actually more
females now who actually you know
women's Wednesday is about 50/50 yeah
even even the crash cause it's if
there's a lot of women but for some
reason they just don't watch me on
YouTube really maybe their husbands
dragon yeah dragged them along with oh
they probably so what what's easier
rent HMO or went to serviced
accommodation are you know I think they
both have their different stresses
because with set serviced accommodation
your stress
would be like the only stress arenas oh
yeah maybe a couple days without booking
reducer than that yeah then for me I
think like I know now obviously being
experienced that there will be a booking
eventually especially when you get a
long term booking Lord direct bookings
nice yeah and then so what we do what
we've been doing now anyway is not kind
of leaving it to Airbnb and booking comm
now you know we're trying to build
relationships with other agencies you
know who hell's they're corporate
employees and that kind of stuff or
remote workers who maybe who are flying
from America for a week or something and
we want to get more direct bookings like
that yeah so you don't want to really
leave it in for the hands of the air B&B
but and then obviously there's HMO which
I that one's that one's good but it's a
lot of work initially that's that's more
initial work groundwork than you've got
to get all the people rented in but once
that's done then it's fairly it's a lot
more passive than obviously having to
turn over an essay all the time what do
you when you do a rent to HMO do you
find a property that's got the potential
to be a chat out or do you find it
currently that's the thing say that's so
we do both say we do both because I
remember that
we find current HMOs because obviously
they got the license and everything and
it's a lot more easier to just kind of
and use it and they're ready they got
fire doors and my kind of stuff yeah so
that's awesome but then I then after
doing that I cut then I actually kind of
remembered back back on your early day
training your leaders I'll find a
three-bedroom house mine four bedroom
house with two reception rooms yeah so
nuts and we're looking at doing those as
well but in reading you know the prices
are it's not that it's not super cheap
for these ones for this type of housing
when you turn HMO what I found is that
in turn HMO sorry a property into HMO
there's usually more profit because if
it's currently HMO they might be a bit
greedy Michael exactly yeah however the
costs will be a lot less yeah if it's
already a HMO the cost will be less but
you might just make that problem exactly
so that's that's that's the that's
obviously the trade-off right now
because it's like do you want speed or
are you you you happy to take a little
bit less profit to begin with take a bit
more time to do it up or whatever change
into hmm
women reservists accommodation I mean my
achieve is what better way to penetrate
to rent as a strategy it's not for
everybody no it's not I mean you you've
got your your full time property now
you've got a bit of time yeah what did
you when you left University what year
did you finish what yeah have you ever
had a job I did have a job yeah so I was
in software sales I was working for a
u.s. software company yeah that was
awesome I learn a lot there and that now
I've quit that in June yeah yeah yeah
quit that in June last year this year oh
you just quit yeah yeah I quit in this
edition Joe yeah I was there for about
18 months or so was it scary Quirinal no
it wasn't because that's what people
were asking me is all when I quit how
did you quit why did you do that and
obviously I had the the income from from
the rent to rents yeah covering it so I
would really relieved yeah it's a big
deal well I mean for 24 26 year old it's
just finished you night a year or so ago
exactly then quit good job yeah yeah but
don't get me wrong man that was good I
mean like most of my people most of my
friends who graduated jobs I didn't go
to a graduate I didn't want to graduate
all wanted to get into sales always knew
I was like performance-based money and
then they were struck people struggling
to get 25k 28k maybe even lucky to get a
30k job and then I mean I was there else
making over double my friends right
straight out of the bat and a lot of my
friends had finished you know a year or
two ahead of me so they had a head start
to me but then for me getting into sales
I was already making more money than
than they were which is awesome so you
had a good job that you enjoyed but you
were able to call it at 26 making more
money in property I mean so it's a
remarkable story really yeah it's cool
and I think that you know a lot of
people you know that watch my videos
that haven't been answer the crash
course I think I just sounds too good to
be true or you know the little voices do
you know what it is it's like it's just
because you haven't experienced it
yourself
don't get me wrong before when I saw
this when I when I was looking at this I
was like I can't get I can't get a rent
to rent okay why would anyone give me a
renter in yeah I was like Who am I
that's what that's what I think that's
what goes in most people's minds anyway
prior to when you're starting anything
when did it click the way you just
thought you know what I can totally do
this I can go out and do this walk when
did that well to be honest I mean like I
had is honestly it has to be the crash
course it has to be the crash course
because everyone's there you see the
amount of how many because when you're
watching on YouTube you don't really
realize how many people are actually
interested in this kind of stuff and you
go then this 800 a thousand people all
wanting to do the exact same thing
people who are already successful your
average Joe people who are just normal
people you know it doesn't really matter
what ethnicity you are what age you are
you know what you're like a pastors or
wherever it is able to education
backgrounds you know it doesn't really
matter what that is it just matters
where you want to go yeah and the effort
you're gonna ultimately put into that
and I think when you have the knowledge
it then gives you a level of confidence
that you can only dream of definitely
because without some people people say
to me I haven't got the confidence I'm
thinking you know it's your issues not
confidence its knowledge if you have the
knowledge you don't have the confidence
definitely because that's that's it
really if you know more than the person
who you're talking to about whatever the
subject yes then then you're in a good
position if people had my brain or even
your brain there would be confident
exactly knowing what we know about the
subject yeah it's just knowing people
that's what stops people oh what if I
can't answer this question you have that
question then look like an idiot but
yeah that's when I learn like in my in
my old job is that if you didn't know
anything then what you say is I'll just
take this offline I'll come back to you
yeah once I had the answer or I don't
deal with this part of the answer or the
business or whatever my partner knows
I'll get me on sin come back yeah yeah
I'm not getting stressed out I don't
know the answer then you look
unprofessional you come up more
professional admitting you don't know
something yeah let me get back to you on
that
have you got any other questions you
were to go look into exactly and that's
that's the best way what what's your
strongest reason why like why are you
really doing this well they'd be honest
with you when I think when I was about
five years old my parents split open but
five years old I've been living with my
mum single mum she's been living sorry a
living living she's been working crazily
for me and my two sisters since we were
since I was five and my when my younger
sister was literally just born so my
mom's been my mom's had it tough but
she's also been
wrong she's she got a property she got
two properties actually she did during
this period she she was real
entrepreneur self she opened up a post
office and all that kind of stuff she
put us through private school for some
periods of our life not a full period of
my life but some some other period so
you know really appreciate what she's
done for us and how I kind of turned out
I think is but it's largely to do with
her and obviously how she's brought us
up
she wants to I've actually kind of
employed her now in the business which
is awesome because she wants she could
see what you don't want to do anymore
working and stuff so I kind of employed
her now just to do a little just a few
little jobs in that which is awesome
but ultimately my wife is just to really
just pay off the mortgages that she for
her houses pay for anything that my
sisters want to be honest like fact my
my youngest this is now in
Interuniversity
I actually want to get her a property
down there so she can stay there with
her friends and she can actually maybe
start renting out rooms and stuff over
there but ultimately it has to be my
girls yeah it has to be them they're my
wife they're the reason what I do but
then there's also a few other reasons as
well that there's a few there was a few
people in my past as well who actually
really doubted me or like you know they
would say bad things about me or just
like and they trying to put me down you
know you get these kind of haters as
well so I actually kind of use that as
fuel as well because people thought that
I may have been like a bum or something
or didn't really have any goals or a
plan stepped out or something like that
so it's quite nice to just even though
it's not probably the best source of
energy but it still works sometimes that
you know if I ever sometimes if you feel
low or something you know you might you
would think about your why I think about
my mom on my sisters and then sometimes
you think about something else I'm like
okay I got to make sure that these guys
just do not get the satisfaction to ever
think that they were right yeah so that
all there's all these other kind of
stuff that kind of motivates me and yeah
that's it so when you say people who
didn't believe he used um what were your
school yeah school University past
relationships as well I mean like I've
learned a lot about relationships as
well I mean like I had I had I used to
have I probably bout ten
real close mates lost about half of
those because you kind of then realize
who your friends are when what as well
well just that's the thing that I mean
like just I know I think it could be
honestly like envy I mean there's a lot
of envy that can go around there down in
property yeah I mean I'm innocent
property just like starting to succeed
yeah just in general then you kind of
realize who who's important to you and
who actually is there for you and who's
against you so it's quite interesting to
kind of learn how how things play out
you you realize who you friends are way
I guess it's not not just when you're
going through your struggles I've found
that sometimes when I'm struggling oh if
I'm in a bad patch in my life there'll
be people that will be there for me yeah
but then when I'm succeeding those
people aren't now yeah it's almost like
they're only able to connect with me
well exactly and that's that's not what
you want you want to be around people
who can support you in both ways not
those all when you're down oh cool and
now I can talk to you now I can relate
to you exactly now I can relate to you
now because you've got problems like
I've got problems yes but actually you
need people who you can celebrate with
and you can cheer each other on exactly
and then you kind of know who you know
who wants you to win and who doesn't
ultimately that's one of the reasons why
not I don't see myself just as a trainer
but also I'd like to think that I've
created a community where people where
people can actually support one other on
the Facebook group that training
programs okay and I know you've been
active on that and you were pretty vocal
at the crash courses yeah yeah but I
think that's great what how do you find
friends how do you find friends that are
success buddies champion you want that's
the thing I mean like funnily enough so
it's either like my core friends now
like honestly school friends not not
even many university friends honestly
core friends like when I with my friends
from secondary school when I met them at
like 11 to 16 no those are like my main
friends but then how do I find friends I
don't know if I'm fine friends
necessarily but we find business
partners people to work with yeah
because never just because of things
I've learned in the past to be my friend
friend I don't know he has to know them
time after noontime but don't get me
wrong I mean like if this is so many
situations I can throw you can relate to
it's all that you actually can work so
much better with a stranger sometimes
than someone that you've known for a
really long time yeah and I think that's
really important too you know
not just close off to not close off to
people you don't even know there's
people who know have never even network
or you never pick up a phone or never
say hi to us to a stranger but you never
know what we're where they can lead
well we're taught growing up not talk
strangers but actually that's where
money comes frankly money comes from
people anyway maybe if you only if you
only want to do business of people that
you know really well then you're gonna
there's 7 billion people on the planet
why say I'm only gonna do business of 20
people you're just gonna you're just
gonna get your network is going to be
0.0001 percent of what it should be just
because you don't want to talk to
strangers because you were told that
when you were a kid so for people
wanting to get started with the rent
rent strategy hmm three biggest tips
piece of advice from someone that's done
it yeah go I would say definitely get
your website get your knowledge and
which one is it's gonna be it's gonna
have to be cut off to save get your
contracts and everything yeah those are
the things that for me anyway that those
are the barriers in your head that oh I
need these contracts if I have the
contracts or I've got my website and and
I've got my knowledge yeah I think those
are the key things as long as you have
the you've got the contracts you go all
that stuff then you should have enough
confidence to go out and so you can show
your show your product
okay someone says they're ready to sign
on the dotted line and you don't know
what the deadline is exactly exactly
because then we find the dotted line the
same time there you can you can you can
you can focus too much on I need to know
what the contracts gonna look like later
but actually if you're not viewing
properties you not seeing people so
that's the thing is an analysis of over
paralysis over analysis yep everyone
whatever order that goes in so you
you've done you've obviously watched a
lot of YouTube videos you've done a bit
of training with us what were you
devised to someone that was thinking
about doing some training with ourselves
or Christ I'm definitely just go for it
I mean like that's the thing I mean it's
free first of all the craft course is
free just invest in yourself that I'll
say all of you guys can invest in
yourself invest in yourself looks like
people would say so you as I say your
craft process here in London yeah you
have people who are flying from China
they're investing in themselves yeah
they flew from China to come and see you
there's people who are probably like
half an hour down the road is half an
hour's like oh I said this time always
but oh it's 9:00 to 9:00
I'm coming I'm not coming but come on
might invest in yourself that's what I
mean like come on what else are you
gonna do for those hours what you're
gonna do to change your life what you're
doing to secure your future yeah I love
that bro
Hey be good to connect yeah definitely
awesome chat